on the passenger side flanked by poster
board showing the timeline of the
shooting the condemnation of the state's
top lawmen was absolute one hour
14 minutes and eight seconds
that's how long the children waited and
the teachers waited in rooms 111 to be
rescued
and while they waited
the on-seat commander
waited for a radio
and rifles
then he waited for shields
then he waited for swat
lastly he waited for a key that was
never needed
according to the timeline the gunman
entered the school around 11 33 am and
here's the door it took some 80 minutes
before the police entered the classroom
and killed the 18 year old
the screen grab from a security camera
shows armed police in a school corridor
just minutes after the killer entered
three minutes after the subject entered
the west building
there was sufficient number of armed
officers wearing body armor
to isolate distract and neutralize the
subject
the only thing stopping a hallway of
dedicated officers from in room 111
and 112 was the on-scene commander
who decided to place the lives of
officers for the lives of children
the command on the ground was peter
redondo the school district's chief of
police
he's been giving evidence this week
behind closed doors but neither he nor
his lawyers have publicly responded to
the latest criticism of his lack of
action
and at a school board meeting monday
parents of the dead and the survivors
demanded police accountability
more angry that they're trying to cover
up a lot of things and trying to hold us
back from speaking
also
just that they should have just gone in
there and done their job basically they
just didn't do their job
and another parent talks about the
impact on her daughter who survived we
were asking her questions how she felt
about school and she just started
breaking down because
she don't really want to talk about it
like she lived through it and
she don't want to relive it and she is
afraid to go back to school she's just
scared it might happen again
as yet there's been no public criticism
in the special committee of a law that
allowed an eighteen-year-old to buy an
ar-15 assault rifle three years before
he could legally buy a beer
in the eyes of many who lost loved ones
the law as much as police in action
should also be held accountable
mike hanna al-jazeera washington